is the US ambassador to the United
Nations Linda Thomas Greenfield hello to
you
um thank you for joining us on the
program this morning Madam Ambassador um
European leaders Summit
um explain to us why there is American
representation there
like we are part of a unified effort
with our European allies to show our
strong support for Ukraine but also to
condemn Russia in as loud and as strong
a voice as we can in the U.S is very
much a part of that and we support the
efforts of our European colleagues and
want to make sure that Ukraine knows it
has it has our support
and Madame Ambassador you are very keen
along with the other European leaders
that are surrounding you there that
Russia has accountability and continues
to have accountability for the war in
Ukraine by creating a new register of
damage caused can you tell us more about
that
look we have seen the destruction
that Russia has wrought on the Ukrainian
people we see the missiles every day
bombing buildings and bumming their
infrastructure and they have to be held
accountable for that and the registry is
one step toward laying that Foundation
of accountability so that in the future
we have the mechanism we have the legal
basis for holding Russia accountable
particularly as this relates to damages
yeah I mean a
Russia will I'm guessing just basically
not recognize it
well of course they're not going to
recognize that they don't recognize that
they are committing acts of uh they're
committing war crimes they're committing
human rights violations what they are
doing is unconscionable and we have to
start the process of holding them
accountable and and have them in
particular with this registry be called
to the mat to pay for the damages that
they have caused
at the UN I think recommended this
register some six months ago something
like um last November why has it taken
so long to find Partners to support it
do you think
well it all of this is a process and we
have worked with uh with our colleagues
both at the UN and here in in Europe to
find a basis that is supported by the
majority and we're here and we are
speaking with one voice and we know that
Ukraine appreciates that and we know
that Russia hears us
I'm sure you'll be having lots of
bilateral meetings while you are there
in Iceland beautiful part of the world
um how are you um the United States
um and the UN trying to make sure that
war fatigue does not impact on the
continuing support for Ukraine
we know that Ukraine is fighting a war
for all of us that this is about saving
the world uh as we say in in the U.N
Charter uh from the scourge of war and
so we have to stand with Ukraine as long
as it takes and President Biden has been
very clear that we will stand with
Ukraine as long as it takes and I heard
that message delivered by all of the
leaders from Europe yesterday
Russia's aggression against Ukraine
cannot be uh uh cannot succeed and
Russia cannot be allowed
to
benefit from what has been an unprovoked
war and unprovoked aggression against
the Ukrainian people
How concerned are you madam Ambassador
we're heading into election territory
here in the United Kingdom also in in
your country and if there's a change of
leadership that support will continue on
for Ukraine
look our support for Ukraine has been
bipartisan from the beginning the
president has worked with his colleagues
in Congress to ensure that we get the
support both financial and moral support
for the Ukrainian people and that
support will continue despite
the election the doubts that are
expressed are are not doubts that are
being expressed by those in leadership
positions
what would you consider to be a
successful conclusion of the talks that
you're taking place in at the moment
well we've seen the the success of these
talks we have a registry that we're all
signing on to and we've had a meeting in
which we are unified in our condemnation
of Russia and we're unified in our
support for Ukraine that was our goal
and we have achieved that as we continue
even as we continue those talks today
and how are you enjoying your time in
Reykjavik in Iceland beautiful part of
the world isn't it
uh it's very peaceful this is my very
first time coming to Iceland and I have
to congratulate and commend the people
of Iceland and the government of Iceland
for organizing this extraordinary
meeting and uh and being such great host
yeah we we love Iceland here in the UK
Madam Ambassador unless they beat us at
soccer at football because it's a tiny
population compared to us but they do
beat us on occasion but yeah you're
right it is a beautiful part of the
world good luck with the rest of the
conference thank you very much indeed
for joining us thank you
thank you kay